Created accessible,
engaging learning materials
for public health
professionals out in the field
that they could fit
in around their busy
lives to build their
skills in public health
social marketing and
ethical programming
to address childhood
obesity and weight stigma.
With the Strategic
Training Initiative
for the Prevention
of Eating Disorders,
we have a case method
creation program
where we develop
curriculum materials that
can be used in public health
classrooms around the country
or around the globe to bring
in topical, cutting edge issues
and eating disorders prevention
into public health classrooms.
We'd created, I think,
eight teaching cases
for traditional
in-person classrooms.
Very excited about that.
We're a great body of work.
Never been done before,
anything like that.
And then we realized, how many
people can we possibly reach
if we stay limited to
traditional in-person
implementation, teaching
in a traditional classroom?
How many people who are
public health practitioners
can get back into a college
or university classroom?
They don't have time.
They're working on the field.
They need the education
to come to them.
They need training
opportunities to come to them,
to meet them where they're at.
Whether they're working
on this before work,
after work, on
weekends, on vacations,
we need to give them something
that they can really integrate
into their busy working lives.
Some of the key design elements
that we need to figure out
is, how do we capture the
experimentation and the energy
of case method teaching
and active learning
in an in-person classroom where
you can see your classmates
work together?
You can build off
each other's energy.
How do we capture that and bring
that into a digital platform
where they are not face-to-face
in a literal sense?
They're not in
the same classroom
with their classmates on this.
But we still want to capture
that energy, that engagement,
and that spirit of
experimentation.
And to being able to work
really collaboratively together,
even though they're not sitting
in the same room together.
That was the
overarching challenge,
because we were very committed
to the case method teaching
and active learning principles.
Because we know
the evidence shows
this is the strongest
way to ensure people
understand the material, can
internalize the material,
and most importantly,
translate it to apply it out
in field settings after
they're out of the classroom.
We want to change the way
public health practice is done.
They need to have
all those steps
to be able to translate it into
their work out in the field.
So we needed to keep the energy
and the real evidence base
core of active learning
and case method teaching
but be able to deliver that in
a really very different format,
working in digital communities.
And what was really
helpful with that was that,
working across the different
teams, the partners
that we worked with.
Dr. Chris Dede with the Harvard
Graduate School of Education,
who has a huge
amount of experience
with teaching and with
case method teaching,
and as well with just
really transformative
technological thinking around,
how do you do this well?
And then two other partners,
Adrienne Phelps-Coco
and Carina Lin.
And they're both
with the Division
of Continuing Education.
And they have a
lot of experience
with enhancing engagement
in online classrooms.
How do you bring that
energy and that connection?
And so we worked with them to
think through some strategies
for how to do that well.
How to bring in certain
activities or certain ways
of integrating communications
within the online course
to bring that sense of community
engagement to the course.
Because that was
really important.
There's a lot of
times when people
talk about online
education, there's
that lack that you don't
get when you don't have
the face-to-face interaction.
And then how do
you maintain-- how
do you get to know your students
over the course of time?
How do you do effective
evaluations of courses
in the online courses?
How do you balance the learning?
There's different ways.
So we really worked
closely with them.
We've benefited so much
from their knowledge.
And they were
responsive and engaged.
And it was just a
really nice meeting
of the minds, a
trans-disciplinary
collaboration across
different schools at Harvard.
So it's a good opportunity.
Our team is just phenomenal.
And then also, we brought
in Megan Kipp, who
is a graduate of
the Harvard Graduate
School of Education TIE,
the Technology, Innovation,
and Education program.
She's been working in the field
for a number of years now.
But she brings that
training from Harvard,
working out in the
field at universities
on digital education.
How do we create online courses
to keep the students involved,
teaching a whole range
of types of topics?
She came on working with
our team in that way.
And she brought in a lot of
really specialized knowledge
of, how do we operationalize
a discussion when it's online?
It's very different than
leading a discussion in person.
How do we handle
sensitive topics online?
And then Carina and Adrienne
were especially helpful
around that, too.
Because one of
the topic areas we
were dealing with was weight
stigma and discrimination.
And there's an enormous
amount of weight shame
that even our learners
may experience.
That's coming into
our virtual classroom,
just like it would in
an in-person classroom.
So there's a lot of kinds
of issues to think through,
some that might be generic, in
a sense, that any online course
needs to handle.
And some courses
that are dealing
with really critical public
health issues or mental health
issues have to be
especially sensitive about.
We provided materials
in different formats.
So we did have the
traditional printout, or PDF
that they could do online,
of the full case that they
would read, that was
extensive and had the story.
We also built in an
interactive case.
So where they'd
almost walk through
it online, and they'd experience
it in a different way.
So that was one way to
bring that case to life
for people versus just
reading it on the platform.
We certainly built in a lot of
work with the discussion boards
and learned a lot
from that experience
in terms of how to evolve
that process going forward.
But there's a lot of
opportunity for people
to interact and respond to each
other's projects or comments.
And then there were
group projects as well.
So thinking through, how would
we bring these smaller groups
together so they can
learn from each other,
to have discussions
with each other?
Setting up a
conference call line
so they can schedule times to
actually have a conversation
and begin building
relationships and then
begin building these
projects so that you
could bring the intimacy
into this larger classroom,
or online approach to learning.
Proud of, because I was involved
with it from start to finish,
was the workshop we ran
as part of this grant.
So we were able to
convene a variety
of instructional designers,
professors, program developers,
course designers from
across Harvard, people
who were interested in
bringing case method learning
to the online space.
Some of them had been doing it.
Some of them were
interested in doing it
at all different
levels of experience.
And they came from
across Harvard,
and one person
even came from MIT,
and convened for a
half-day workshop.
And Chris Dede was a speaker.
We had several speakers.
And they talked about a
variety of very applicable--
we talked about lessons
learned from their experiences.
We talked about specific tools
that were used for evaluation,
for using peer evaluation,
ongoing evaluation that
talked about experience
and smaller goals.
These were tools that people
were just dying to have.
And then we had a mini
hackathon at the very end,
where we had people
work in small teams
and develop an
instructional design
plan for one of
STRIPED's new cases
that we're hoping also to
do the same with, bring it
into the online space
and be able to pilot
it and take that
to the next phase.
So everyone came out with
a deliverable of sorts.
And so they were able to present
their ideas to the broader
workshop.
And they walked away
with that experience
to be able to connect
with other people.
The greatest value,
I think, of that
was what the feedback
was across the board.
We are so grateful to have had
this opportunity to connect
with others across Harvard.
We do not get this
opportunity enough.
There are so many resources here
that we can share and continue
to connect with each other.